i've i've i've i've been on a photo
shoot with jessica in hawaii oh yeah the
one at the waterfall that's right was i
in my nar or my bulge in i think it was
your vulgin one
yeah warchief
i don't play ralph oh the warchief i
made a bulging cosplay and i did a photo
shoot in a waterfall in hawaii you gotta
go to hawaii hawaii hawaii yeah
i love you i went with you
i was there
i was literally there with you on that
show oh man that was so fun so yeah it's
like it's pretty full on like you get
into your cosplay and you're kind of
like in the zone because depending on
like how you made things because when i
make stuff quick sometimes it like
really hurts me when it works i don't
take the time to like make it
comfortable and so then we do the shoot
and then usually like if there's with
this particular case like we went to the
convention right after right which was
rough yeah cause like we got up and we
like airbrushed in the hotel and then we
went to the the jungle took photos and
then
came back touched up again and then went
to the convention for like eight hours
or whatever
that whole convention experience was
rough because every morning jess would
be like we're doing something i know i'm
like six in the morning and i'm like and
and aki and i were like we have to do a
panel in like four hours it's just like
i don't give a [ __ ]
did you go like hiking or something
three hours before your panel
oh my god this is like the toughest
morning of my life all right so it was
like the second to last i think it was
like one of the busiest days in the
corner i was like saturday it was the
saturday baby
what was it amazing hawaii comic con i
met amazing comic-con that's right on
honolulu um and uh it was like six in
the morning and just was like we're
gonna go hiking
and i'm like uh okay but we have to be
back at the convention in like you know
like nine or ten or whatever yeah it was
like yeah it was like 10. like 10 or
something and it's just like no it'll be
an easy hike so then we drive out like
an hour to this mountain called coco
head which is on a hallway
like one of the hardest climbs i've ever
done in my life because the entire
mountain is like a 50 degree incline so
it's it's a it's a mountain that was
originally a lookout post to at the top
of the hill they had a train track that
would go up yeah like directly straight
up and then on top was like a lookout
and you could see out of the ocean
that's cool so what they did is they
removed the train track and so now you
can walk up it as a hike but it gets but
at some points when when you get to the
top of it it gets so steep you literally
have to use the train tracks as a ladder
to climb yeah that sounds good yeah it's
great it's so good it's great is that
just like a light walk for you jess
yeah every day she got happen in like 15
minutes
meanwhile aki and i are like because
we're not used to it right so we're just
like [ __ ] struggling killed it though
well she was dead at the top
there's this great photo where it's like
all of us just like this amazing view of
hawaii just like this and then in the
corner you can just see aki face down on
the ground just dead
and then jess is like don't worry i got
you she pulls out a five hour energy and
just like feeding it to her she just
springs up and she's like i'm ready to
go
oh my god this is just [ __ ] bolts
down the mountain i love aki the whole
time i was like dude do you want to you
know you want to turn around she goes
she goes no no i want to do that
like she was so determined for no reason
it was like she inspired the [ __ ] out of
me man i was like yes yes we will do
this we will ride you know like i was so
[ __ ] pumped because aki was so pumped
she was like no no no no no no go ahead
you go
turn around come back go ahead and i was
like
all right and then she almost died yeah
she was like oh man how hot was it
it was pretty hot that day as well
because it was pretty well literally
like august right when is hawaii
holland i think it's i think it's in
august
i remember it was really freaking hot
because like it's hawaii so like i
assumed it was hot so i just i just was
curious like how hot i was like dripping
sweat yeah
yeah the oceans was beautiful yeah oh my
god
tried to take the aki into the
desk oh yeah ryan and oculus died
but what happened
so
ryan almost died
so we were on we're on waikiki beach and
we were just like hanging out because we
had like a free afternoon or something
right yeah so we're just like yeah let's
just [ __ ] go to the beach yeah so it
was me jess ryan and aki and then they
were out and then aki was out in the
ocean and then i guess there was like a
really bad current that day right so she
kind of got swept out a little bit
and and i think ryan immediately saw
that and was like i'm gonna go help her
out yeah ryan went full like terminator
yeah i got awkward so ryan so ryan jumps
in and grabs her and then immediately it
was kind of like blocked off by this
like a stone wall
right right and then so i guess like so
that you know dangerous wildlife doesn't
come into like this safe area but the
problem was with this stone wall to let
the water come in and out there's like a
little crack
on the wall deadly channel yeah and it's
literally just a channel of water
rushing in and then rushing out over and
over again and but because there was a
current
it just took ryan and aki just
and just swept them out them so quickly
yeah just swept them straight out into
this open water and the entire time jess
and i are just like standing on the
coast just like
oh
it went from like playful laughter to
like genuine concern yeah we had our two
little like a little bottle of malibu
and like orange juice we're standing
there like tourists like oh there goes
ryan no ryan's oh ryan's got another 12.
oh and then the freaking the like and
then the lifeguard had to come out
active lifeguard comes out it's like the
with the surfboard and everything like
put ryan and aki onto the surf one be
like you guys almost drowned out there
we were like oh meanwhile we were
standing on the beach laughing our ass
off with a malibu
four lifeguards like [ __ ] tourists
[ __ ] going out there
shout
and pouring and pouring the lifeguard
says they're like ryan saves aki
it's like the giant like the domino meme
yes yeah
yeah that was fun though
we should go back yes you guys haven't
been in hawaii yet i really really want
to go it's fun as [ __ ] but you guys were
you guys were lucky you got invited to a
convention that's just a free trip well
i got invited because of jess oh okay
because jess knows that organization you
should uh bring these cool youtubers
hook us up just hook us up hey jimmy i'm
looking at you
bring them there's one specific jimmy it
is jimmy yeah i feel like hawaii is one
of those places you don't need to go to
to know you'll like it you're just like
yeah i just know i like it
the convention scene too there is so
lovely like it was it was really chill
oh my god the people are so [ __ ] cool
and so nice and like you get you get
there and then the immediate vibe is
just like ah
how much time did you spend at the
convention versus just in hawaii
yourself i think we were there for like
six hours a day like at our tables yeah
i think so because yeah it was it was
like four to six hours
because like we did a panel every day
and we did a signing every day so i was
like yeah at least like at least the
four-hour like commitment day but
luckily like all of that stuff was done
in the morning so we would normally be
done by like one or two p.m so that's
when they like split it up yeah yeah
yeah two hours in the morning i think
two hours
yeah i think they knew that they were
just like we want you to actually just
like go out and enjoy hawaii so we'll
just do all your commitments all at once
and then you can just [ __ ] off and do
whatever you want jimmy i thought you
were on a convention my man jimmy do you
wanna you wanna get them like close to
yourself oh [ __ ] sorry i'm like leaning
you're leaning back so i'm just trying
to put another pillow behind you if you
wanna just
am i full am i lean is that better oh
yeah